hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the finals of the magnus cross and
invitational uh we are in the
uh final uh game or rather games uh i'm
not going to be able to
cover both of them as the internet
increases simply too slow they would
take me too
too long to cover uh to upload both of
the games so i'm going to merge them in
one as these are blitz games and first
i'm going to show you the critical
position from game one
and then i'm going to show you the
entire game too as
i thought that would be fun so this is
the position here gary has the white
pieces of the photos and the names are
set up for the second game that i'm
going to show
but here giri sacrificed the material
with knight after e5 with
check and while this is not an
objectively great move uh
is there an objectively great move in
blitz chess
so nipple accepted of course very
happily if captures on e5
d captures on e5 and now bishop to c5
putting pressure on on geary's king's
side now you can see there's a lot of
action happening here also upon captures
captures then this bishop is coming to
c6
uh nipple will try a very uh well uh
the checkmate giri and the gear will
have to justify his
uh sacrifice but it's not going to be
easy giri starts with bishop g5
we have h captures and g3h captures and
bishop to c6 napo now ready to checkmate
geary's king here the idea is d4 and
then just rook to h1 checkmate
but giri is ready rook the c1 puts
pressure on the bishop but now nipple
gives it up in
uh well hoping to check made the white
king
we have bishop to e4 geary of course
blocks this and now
captures and captures so uh geary of
course is now down material and nipple
wants to trade off as many pieces as
possible so knight f5
and now queen to a4 by geary and again
while this is objectively not great for
white this is blitz chess and uh we we
really don't care
so here uh we have uh rook the c8 uh
bishop to e7 also very nice forcing
further trades but nipple decides to
start with rook to c8 uh
sorry rook to c8 and now geary goes in
with bishop to f6
attacks nepo's rook here and now the
position is already
very very difficult for for black but
still
very much playable however you have to
play rook the g8 here
the move in the game uh loses the game
terribly so here
rook to h7 was played but now it simply
doesn't work
here gary jumped in with queen to d7
check and now there is no good move for
nepo he completely
got entangled in this and that's just it
and nipple of course defended he played
the
knight g to e7 but now just bishop
captures on e7
and what do you do here uh you can't
really trade but
other than that what's left so he played
queen captures on e7 but now queen
captures on c8 you lose the material
terribly here
uh the bishop also is under attack so
you need to waste the move moving the
bishop
bishop to b6 was played not allowing of
course rook to c7 to win the
the queen right away but now knight to
f6
attacking the rook uh going for queen to
g8 to check
or rather checkmate here so rook the g7
has to be played
and now rook queen to h8 now gear is
completely winning he wants to play
queen to h5 check and there's nothing
nipple can do about it
d3 was played but now comes queen to h5
check rook to g6 and now rook to g4 and
it was in this position that yanni
pomeshi resigned the game
and the game one of the blitz section
goes to uni there is no defense against
queen captures and g6 there is no move
that stops that other than some very
weird moves that we are not gonna cover
so this is how game one ended and now we
are going to the actual game that we are
showing in its entirety and that is game
two we're now um
uh sorry i just uh forgot to uh swap
the names my bad uh let me just
fix that give me a few seconds there we
go
all right that
should do it there we go all right
all right there we go all right fix that
so now we have jan with the white pieces
and the niche has the black pieces now
aeon now needs uh needs to win the game
to force uh armageddon otherwise it's
geary who takes it all
so jan with the white pieces decided
okay we're not going to go for the
sicilian one more time
we're going to play b3 we go for the
nymphs of h larsen attack and let's see
how geary deals with this as now
everything is on the line uh
nipple absolutely must win with the
white pieces so gary starts with the d5
and this is a very principal decision
for any time format when your opponent
opens on the flank you want to control
the center
uh bishop to b2 and now bishop to f5 by
geary we have d3
and interestingly uh nipple had this uh
position with the white pieces against
many strong players he had it against
grishok against lebanon he had against
david anton guihara but he never
actually won a game against um
such strong opposition with this but for
this uh
must-win game he decided to go with this
for giri and here gary strikes with c5
and interestingly already as of move
three we have a completely new game
so here knight to d2 continuing
development preparing to strike with e4
and now knight to f6 by geary we have g3
preparing to fiance to the light square
bishop as well and
knight the c6 now we have bishop to g2
and now
e5 so massive controlling the center by
giri
we have e4 striking in the center bayan
and now
captures capture so the capture sd
captures bishop has to go back
and now knight g to f3 eon is now also
ready to castle with queen to c7 by giri
and castles now we have bishop to e7
and now knight to c4 putting even more
pressure on the e5 pawn all of
the pieces are attacking that e5 pawn
and uh giri could catch run c4 but he
decides to go rook to d8
first attacks nipples queen nepal moves
that queen to b1
and only now bishop captures on c4 you
don't want to lose your central e pawn
so b captures on c4 now the queen is on
a semi-open b
file hence the queen b1 move uh and uh
here
geary castles we have rook to e1 now
adding additional protection to the pawn
developing the rook
and knight the d7 now preparing to
strike in the center maybe with f5 or
maybe with a solid f6
with bishop to f1 now shifting the
bishop to a useful diagonal
because here even though nipple has the
bishop pair it's not
doing all that much it's pretty hemmed
in by the pawns
so knight's the d4 this is the the dream
uh just uh you know having a knight on
an excellent central outpost and if bla
if white eliminates it then you improve
your pawn structure even further
so uh here we have knight to d2
preparing to strike in the center with
f4 and now bishop to g5 uh of course
we're getting ready for that idea now
the bishop of the pawn and the queen are
helping out with the defense of the f4
square
so bishop captures on b4 we have bishop
captures on d2 first
now rook to d1 and only now c captures
on d4 we have rook captures on d2
and now knight to c5 again putting
pressure on that e4 pawn
and bishop to d3 defending it uh we have
rook to d6
now gary wants to get his rook somehow
into the game maybe rook a6 rook a3 put
some pressure along
those lines and now rook to e2 by nipple
uh we have rook to a6 as planned and now
queen to c1 now nipple trying to get
some sort of an attack going maybe with
queen to g5 f4 maybe f5 maybe he can go
h4 h5
uh this is now going full barbarian mode
so rook to a4 by giri
and now queen to g5 with f6
uh pushing the queen back now queen to
h5 and here
rook to a3 now with a double attack on
the bishop here
sonya po needs to defend this we have
rook to d2 and now
queen to a5 putting pressure on the rook
here so nepal moves it back
and now only now as the a pawn is
attacked twice
rook captures on a2 so rook to b1
not allowing the trade uh and here we
have queen back to c7 so gary grab the
pawn here he
has everything nicely defended on the
king side the center center is closed
now he can start pushing here
maybe a5 a4 a3 there are many ways black
can play this
so rook to f1 getting support for this
f4 thrust
and now uh we have rook to a5
uh we have queen to g4 uh but now rook
to
a3 again putting pressure on the bishop
here so
f4 nipple no longer wants to wait he
wants to make something happen he needs
a win here otherwise uh well it's giri
who wins it all the title along with the
sixty thousand dollars
so e capture sun f4 g captures on f4 and
now
knight captures on d3 gear is just
eliminating all of the attackers
c captures now rook captures on d3
grabbing yet another pawn now he has the
pass deep on the past a pawn
and nepo needs to uh to do something
otherwise he can just resign he pushes
e5 again full-on barbarian mode just
pushing forward
but rook to e3 now by geary just uh
supporting that
uh e file not allowing that pawn to do
any damage
we have queen to g2 now attacking the b7
pawn and here our gear just calmly
trades with queen to c6 and here
nipple could actually go for this rook
captures on b7 idea winning a pawn but
it doesn't really help all that much for
example captures captures now if
captures an e5
and what do you do here if f captures a
rookie to check
what do you do king g1 now even d3 is
coming
and not much for for white to hope for
here uh if you trade rook captures king
captures
again this is just winning d1 check the
uh
the d1 uh d2 checkered d1 queen
so you have to play something like this
then rook captures here and it's black
is just up too much material so instead
uh giri uh sorry nepo tried queen to d5
with check forcing a trade there
in order to get his pawn all the way to
d5 uh but giri says that's not a problem
just queen captures on the five c
captures and now trades in the center f
captures
and now uh well capturing here uh
uh is fine but now first rook captures
on b7
uh grabbing that pawn eliminating one of
the past pawns
but now just e captures on f4 we have
rooked the c1 by nippo
and now f3 gary continues pushing his
pass pawn we have king to f2 blocking
and now
rook to e2 with check we have king to f1
and now rook to e5 so what you do here
not a lot to do you're down too much
material
rook c the c7 was played hoping for
maybe a mouse slip or something if you
replace something like a5 there's still
a way for nipple to win this
for example captures and then after king
h8 captures king here and this will be
checkmate so
you always uh you know need to hope that
your opponent
makes some sort of a mistake but here we
have rook to g5 nepal defends the pawn
and is ready to go down
with the rook so here we have h4 trying
to get that rook away from the defense
of the g7 pawn
but just rook to g4 yeah giri says
that's not happening
we have king to f2 blocking the pawn not
just rook to g2
we have king the f1 and now you are
geary here
uh feel free to pause the video and win
the game and with it sixty thousand
dollars and
the uh title of the champion of the
magnus crossing invitational
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always pushing
that past pawn and for those
who just want to enjoy the show uh yeah
you can push that one but
this one is much faster so whoever did
this uh congratulations as this is what
giri played and it was in this position
on mu 44 that the ani pon issue resigned
to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh your
rook the g1 is coming this comes with
check then the queen gets promoted
and this is unstoppable if you capture
the rook it's still checkmate queen
to f1 check king g3 and now just queen
g1 check the king has to go to the h
file rook to f3 will be checkmate
uh so after this rook to have to move uh
jan resigned and uh
an amazing amazing uh finals between
anish giri and yani pomshi the first day
started a bit slow four draws then two
more draws and then
sorry then one more draw and then uh
well it was just crazy it was
incredible how young bounced back and
forced thai breaks but now giri wins
both of the games and it was really
incredible how he won the first one
uh the the sacrifice wasn't really the
most correct move but
like i said is there such a thing as a
correct move in blitz not
really so gary wins uh in great style
game one and he
just punishes yon in game two for for
simply you know going full on barbarian
mode he he kept calm he just you know
played all the right moves and then
he won the entire event so
congratulations to anish
and you know also for nepal for such
incredible play
uh they were both deserving of the title
but you know as usual
there can only be one winner uh so
that's the game or rather those are the
games hope you guys enjoyed them and the
coverage this short coverage of the
entire event um we are now of course
going to cover some other things that
are happening in the chess world and of
course then we are returning to the good
stuff
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
edgars rusteka
mikhail carlin christian viscers
sebastian
bill and john king for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day